for a long time i've been hearing about
secret societies
some people claim they are harmful
organizations and others say they are
useful to society
i think their story is important
and could be affecting our lives
there have always been secret societies
to retain knowledge
in the arab world
was completely fascinated by the idea of
secret societies western secret
societies
there are all sorts of secret societies
there are political ones there are
criminal ones and indeed there are awful
ones
the facts are there it's just that we
each sometimes interpret them
differently
crashed into one of the towers
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
secret societies are fiercely
compartmentalized but there's a level
above them that's where the real game is
going on
washington dc was indeed laid out
according to masonic symbolism
do secret societies exist
and are they trying to rule the world
from the shadow
[Music]
i have always thought of myself as a
free thinker
i am always hungry for knowledge
when i was at school my favorite
subjects were mathematics physics and
literature
i love numbers and shapes
and at the same time i enjoy a good
story
and i love mystery
[Music]
mysteries generally propel my curiosity
and need to know
my curiosity made me think of what is
called secret societies
like the illuminati the freemasons
and many other secret societies they say
have existed since a long time ago
and there are alleged records of some of
them
and claims that their members reached as
far as to rule nations
and stories about strange rituals
exercised in their meetings
what are these secret societies
do they really exist and what is their
purpose
when i started the journey to search for
answers
i got lost
lost between many secret societies
each one has its own rules and
objectives
the freemasons the illuminati the
resercians skull and bones and many
others we hear of
and maybe others we don't
so i decided i should start by talking
to someone who did a lot of research on
this topic
[Music]
i reached david ike
maybe he can show me the way
hi david you have investigated secret
societies for a long time can you please
tell me more about the origins of secret
societies there have always been
um secret societies well as far back as
we can
ascertain because there's always been
groups of people that wanted to retain
secrets
secrets to hoard knowledge
if i have a certain
highly important level of knowledge and
you don't i am in a position of power
over you so the objective of secret
societies is actually to keep essential
knowledge hidden from the public
we live in a world that actually
is made up of two worlds one is the
world that the population live in and
that is limited in terms of the
knowledge that it has
this knowledge is kept from the
population by not
allowing it into the public arena and
this other world is made up of a global
network of secret societies in which
this knowledge is passed on through the
generations of carefully chosen
initiates at the core of the court
overwhelmingly coming from a network of
interbreeding families so being a member
of a secret society for instance like
the freemasons you would have access to
knowledge that nobody else has
these secret societies are fiercely
compartmentalized you look at justin
freemasons as an example the bottom
three levels of degree the so-called
blue degrees and there's 33 levels
and you only progress to the next level
which is what the next level of
knowledge if that level decides you are
worthy of it or you're the kind of
person that should have it you have a
say the freemasons
you have the jesuit order you have the
knights templar and they appear of
course compartmentalized in their
individual pyramids but there's a level
above them
and at that level
at which it doesn't officially exist
that's where the real
game is going on
what is written about the templars is
that they were formed in the middle ages
they were warriors
they say they invented banking as we
know it and they amassed incredible
fortunes and they offered loans to kings
and nations as a way to control them
then it is said they became builders and
pirates and grew more popular and
powerful until they were outlawed by the
king of france and their leaders were
burnt at the stake
but many say they continued in secret
and became more occult
it seems there are many secret societies
who people believe are ruling the world
or producing its leaders
like the fraternity called ordo novi
templi or new templars that is said to
be behind the rise of hitler
the fraternity was founded by york lance
von diebenfels
a racial theorist and guido von list a
nociltist
lynn picknet is a writer and researcher
whose work on secret societies is very
useful
i think she could help answer a few
questions
hi lin
you did
an extensive research on the templars
yeah yeah we did the research yes
so what can you tell me about secret
societies and their relation to power
there are all sorts of secret societies
there are political ones there are
criminal ones and indeed there are awful
ones i always say that the paranormalist
thing
is the things that happen and the occult
is things you choose to do you know so
like join a society
and ritual magic for example which is
all about focusing your will through
rituals and they hope to change the
actual world through their will whether
or not they manage it or not another
matter do you think there is a link
between secret societies
and
powerful political organizations
such as the nazis
the nazis have their roots in a sort of
semi-mystical belief system called
ariosity which actually came from the
19th century but built up in importance
after the first world war when germany
was beaten and germany felt it needed to
build up its national pride so
they became very obsessed with ariosity
which was basically the idea
that the aryan race was in a very
ancient race that um had ancient wisdom
and had mystical roots um and
was going to rule the world so the idea
of a unified identity and purpose
could very well be one of the main
reasons or motivations behind such
groups actually i think it's almost like
part of human dna in a way is that you
you know you think i know something that
they don't know and then you say you say
you say to somebody do you want to know
my secret you know and it's it's
actually it's power it's quite
interesting that you have uh the united
states of all places you know being
actually founded by unapologetic
freemasons i mean you know they they
were you know there was nothing sinister
about them because at that time
certainly the pre-masonic ideal was
about enlightenment so you have you know
george washington you know benjamin
franklin a huge number of
of the founding fathers were in fact
green masons
they believed there is magic in symbols
no
washington dc was indeed laid out
according to masonic um symbolism to
stamp the new
center the new capital with the masonic
presence if you like and perhaps some of
them did believe it did you know protect
it in some way
everything is attached by a very thin
thread
the facts are there
it's just that we each sometimes
interpret them differently what are we
supposed to do
we can only speculate when there is a
gap in the information
true
but there is a limit beyond which it's
no longer speculation it becomes
just fertile imagination
[Music]
according to certain research some
secret societies also existed in the
arab world
some from a long time ago like the
assassins and the baktash
and it seems that they may have been an
inspiration to some western secret
societies
and there are claims that some arab
muslim great thinkers and figures were
in one way or another linked to a secret
society
we may hear negatively of the freemasons
and consider it an accusation but we all
admire some of their figures for their
contribution to humanity
this can be surprising especially when
these figures are arabs
this is something worth exploring
i will talk to iheb germazi an mit
researcher and harvard phd candidate
he can tell us about secret societies in
the arab world it would be very good to
start by saying that
seeing
freemasonry and secret societies as
a
particularly evil
organization in the arab world
especially
is mostly a product of the second half
of the 20th century
but
if we look at the 19th century and the
beginning of the 20th century we would
see that the elites
in the arab world
was completely fascinated actually by
the idea of of secret societies western
secret societies and western free
masonic lodges the first reason was that
the freemasonry is an elitist
group that is interested in hiring and
adopting as brothers
those who are proved that they are
influential in their societies the
second reason they are different from
the colonial materialist racist
program
and perhaps most importantly that they
claim they had a spiritual aspect to
them can you please talk to me a little
bit about the decline of secret society
especially in the arab world what
happened to them they were so popular
and all of a sudden everybody
wants to stay away from them
the the problem with freemasonry
basically when it when it started
one of them that included the elite the
elite starting having a problem with
freemasonry
happened
when
the
colonialism ended
a lot of the local elite
wanted to be to be as far as possible
from any western lineage
the second reason it's an important one
is actually the creation of the state of
israel
that
zionism in that sense was always
affiliated to some sort of a big masonic
world conspiracy
and linking zionism and freemasonry made
it very difficult for a lot of arab
intellectuals to want to be fitted to
freemasonry or to acknowledge the fact
that they were or they want to the third
one perhaps is that
it is true that especially and this is
relatively new in the last 30 years
mostly but since
the
link between
freemasonry
and occultist societies and zionism to a
certain extent and imperial powers
that new network
of
some sort of western
all powerful
secret organizations made it almost
impossible today not very difficult to
claim any affiliation to freemasonry
without fearing
the repercussions of it because of that
new idea that was adopted by the public
that freemasonry is an evil organization
[Music]
it is normal that people gather
organize
keep secrets
and favor those who think like them
it's human nature to collaborate and
partner
and this has served humanity well
since the hunter-gatherer times
through the ages of the pyramids until
the formation of modern
states some groups may have taken it too
far
others maybe not
that's why i'll keep asking questions
[Music]
[Music]
and
[Music]
you